as our first speaker and he'll tell us
about four analysis and in a general
analysis of the high dimensional
expanders so take away Max great
okay great as Dora said uh I'll be
talking about extending the theory of
analysis to high dimensional expanders
um I want to give maybe a slight
overview of what I'm going to talk about
in these two lectures in a slight
disclaimer so the first thing that we're
going to do is we're going to try to
extend sort of this core theory of
having Affiliated composition and sort
of L2 or spectral based properties that
we discussed in the last couple of days
and we'll see a beautiful basis student
addiction dinner film this and Harsha
that will focus on constructing in the
first lecture in the second lecture
we'll actually be largely independent
from the first we won't explicitly need
the tools that we develop we'll talk a
little bit about properties Beyond uh a
spectral case things like
hyperconductivity that was mentioned
yesterday and we'll see how high
dimensional expenditures are related to
this type of behavior that we won't sort
of prove this explicitly
um okay so let's start where is the
black
marker
so uh
just as a reminder I think people
probably do not need this at
this point but what I'm going to do is
write up sort of the properties of the
Fourier composition that I would like to
generalize to uh to high dimensional
expanders so we all know very well at
this point
we have a function
on Boolean Cube I'm going to use K as
dimension in this in this talk if I
write something else please catch me
people use lots of different things for
intervention uh this is usually the one
that's used in HDX
so if I have some function mapping the K
dimensional Cube to the reals then of
course it has avoida composition
and moreover we saw that it's typically
useful to divide this into levels
corresponding to the size of the set s
and in some sense this is you know F we
can write f i is equal to the sum of uh
sets of size I
guys and this is sort of the
contribution coming from Level I this is
the the Fourier degree at level live we
talked about this and and largely this
is sort of the we're going to look at
generalizing these types of foia level
functions
so there are sort of three properties
that I'm going to care about
the first is sort of a moral property
which is basically what I just said I'm
gonna once
that this function fi in my
decomposition sort of comes from Level I
combinatorially somehow this is like the
degree
or level
I heart
of
here this is sort of literally the case
right this is coming from the sum of I
juntas these characters that only depend
on my coordinates when we move over to
complex land which I'll be more explicit
about these will be like functions that
sort of come from the isets that come
from Level I of the complex and get
lifted up to level K
okay the second and third thing or maybe
a bit more explicit we want
orthogonality or at least approximately
uh
just writer orthogonal
um so we want that fi
of J is equal to zero as long as I is
not equal to J and this implies some
version of parts of all theorem which we
saw was very useful right so this was
just saying I can express the standard
two Norm of of S as uh you know I'll
write it as
just the sum over these level functions
if you expanded this out you get the sub
and the squared for your coefficients
but this is sort of a coarse version of
the parts of all so we'll want to
generalize this and finally
this is a property that Noam talked
about uh we'll want our basis to be
an eigen basis
with respect to certain operators in
particular Noam talked about this with
respect to the noise operator right he
showed that applying this to a character
of size I got you at eigenvalue of rho
to the i in particular if we apply it to
level I we got the T row of f i
was equal to rho to the i f i and we saw
how this sort of dampened higher levels
and how this was very useful so we'll
want to maintain this behavior
um the noise operator is
a little bit more complex to represent
the pi dimensional expanders you can do
it but I'll want to largely focus on a
simpler invoice process which just
corresponds to the hypercube graph where
I pick one instead of picking each
coordinate and resampling it with some
probability of one minus rho I'm going
to pick one random coordinate and and
resample it so this is like the lazy
hypercube graph where I have Hamming
distance one but I'm adding some
laziness to allowing myself to go back
so I'll write this as like Q tilde of K
it's the lazy hypercube graph and you
can show basically by the same proof
that that Norm went through I'm not
going to go through it explicitly since
it really is the same thing this is also
uh these are both Kaylee wraps on this
objects so you can also think about it
this way they're they're eigenvectors
and this will have eigenvalue uh you can
check uh yourself if you want K minus I
over K times fi and I'm being a bit
explicit about this because we will see
these appear again later in the talk
when we move to high dimensional
expanders
okay so this is a this is the three
properties that we're going to try
hopefully at the end of the talk we'll
have some basis that satisfies these at
least approximately on high dimensional
expansion
number of steps so oh yeah yeah that's
true
yeah okay I think exactly the equivalent
to use this of course oh okay I realize
this uh yeah we'll see that you can also
you can also Define it by looking at
like convex combinations of longer
replacing many things throughout the
complex and just typically how I think
about it okay
so now I want to
unfortunately uh spend a little bit of
time on background on high dimensional
expanders again I read went through this
yesterday but I think at least for me
the first time I saw it I really didn't
get it so I wanna I wanna make sure
everybody really is on the same page
that I'm going to go through it again
um
also you know I didn't say this but
please people interrupted stop me when
uh you know you don't understand
something or have things to say
um okay so let's recall
High dimensional expander definitions
this will include you know like
simplicial complexes these random walks
and operators that already talked about
uh et cetera I will go through all of
this so first of all we're going to
focus on
a simple case of what are called Pure
simplicial complexes
so Pearson push hole complex X just as
it re defined it is basically just a
downward closed hyper graph and I should
say uh
we'll do k k dimensional
I am unfortunately going to depart
slightly from the notation that we had
yesterday because in our world which is
not topology K dimensional things have K
coordinates and the topology World K
dimensional thinks of K plus one
coordinates I am going to use the
notation that X is
this uh collection of subsets
where the top level XK is truly subsets
of size K not of size K plus one should
be very explicit so we don't have a
confusion about this so XK is just some
K uniform hypergraph let's maybe write
sort of on N vertices
this will just be some subset
event choose
and choose K and then all of the lower
levels so we can also see this sort of
in this diagram over here so I'll pull
over in a second all of the lower levels
X I are just given by downward closure
so x i is all of the assets that is
something that's contained in XK so x x
i
right downward
oh sure
and people will typically draw simple
complexes as I guess this is called the
haasi diagram I haven't drawn in the
edges so x0 will be sort of one point
here which is the empty set and then
we'll have X1 which is I haven't labeled
these but these are like the vertices so
this is like one two
over to n and then these will just be
all the sets and the complex and you can
draw edges in this diagram by inclusion
and you can look at these things like
the averaging operators that I read
talked about as moving between levels on
this diagram and we'll sort of move back
to here when we Define things and and
see how the picture looks on the diagram
for me that's the easiest way to think
about all of these things
um okay so this can always be expressed
as this as this diagram I'll mention in
general that people really work read
said this too really work with weighted
simple complexes where there's some
distribution of the top for this talk
again I will do the same thing that I
already did it will assume everything is
super regular and that all the
distributions are are uniform throughout
and maybe in the next talk we'll look at
a case where this isn't true but uh but
here we'll we'll focus on this simple
case okay so now I actually want to
define the averaging operators
uh
I guess if I move this over here people
can still see at least the top levels of
this yeah I realized too late that I'd
just got cut off
okay so now let's talk about sort of
functions on complexes
so uh we call
excuse base of functions
mapping
assets on the complex the reels will be
denoted
by Ci or c i x r would be the right way
to do it so again this is just functions
that apply values to each of these dots
in the in the diagram so f f sort of
lives on this level in the in the
picture
okay we can move uh or sorry I guess I
should say that this is a this is an
inner product space so we can look uh we
can Define the inner product between two
functions on level I
just as you would expect this is the
expectation
foreign
from the complex
of f of Tau
do you have Tau and we'll Define Norms
uh associated with with this Basin again
for Simplicity think of these as uniform
even though maybe really they're they're
not um
but we can sort of always ignore this
and then we can move functions up and
down levels on this complex by using
what are called the real value boundary
and for boundary operators or the
averaging operators uh some variant to
this
so the
averaging
operators
we have the down operator di so I'm
going to keep basically the notation
that I reused which is this index will
tell you the the input level of the
function so this Maps a function on at
level I
down to level I minus one so d i f f
will live on one level Below in this
picture
and this is just given by sort of the
only thing you could naturally do right
if I want to know the value here I'm
going to average the value over
everything that that contains this in my
diagram so it takes this average over
sort of Link or this uh this local part
so this is
the expectation
of f
of Sigma
oh sorry
forgot to write uh
d i of f of Tau
is equal to the expectation
of Sigma
such that Sigma uh contains
Tau so I guess Sigma is drawn from
x i in to be explicit here Sigma is of
size high so Sigma lives here right the
function lives here we have to sum over
things on this level
and
Tao lives what level below that we're
getting the value of okay similarly we
have the adjoint operator this which
lifts up on the complex
so we have the up operator
um and we'll do I minus one
sorry so this should be y minus 1. 2 I
and this is just defined to be the flip
of this so U of I minus one I wonder if
there's a better can people see this or
should I move to a better marker
okay
oh you haven't
okay we'll try thank you
great
okay so we have
the adjoint operator
thank you that's much better
um
UI minus one so now we're taking uh a
function that's on maybe I should say F
Prime so we'll have some f Prime that's
on this level
and now this will take in
so this lifts the level CI so this takes
in when I have UI minus 1 F prime it
takes in a value
say here and again we do sort of the
only thing you could
thing to do I average over the values
one level down
so now I'll look at the
expectation over
uh
F of
Tau
uh it's such that Tau lies in
Sigma
so I was in uh still in x i minus one
okay and are proved that these operators
are adjoint to each other
um
and
I'll actually want to do a little bit
more than this I don't think I mentioned
but I can also compose these operators
right if I wanted to move you know say I
had a function here and I don't just
want to lift it uh one level I want to
lift it all the way up to the top of the
complex I can repeatedly apply the
lifting operator let's say I started I
actually started at this level then I I
lift this to uif and then UI plus one
uif
Etc all the way up to the composition
lifting this up to the top level and how
does this act it's still just this
averaging process right this this what's
the value of the lift of this function
on XK I'm again just averaging over all
the possible values that are below it in
this diagram
all right so I'll also Define sort of
these composed averaging operators
so so your averages here those are
induced from the distribution at the top
level yeah so in in reality there's a
distribution of the top level I induce
distributions below and these are all
with respect to the appropriate
distribution yeah but we'll we'll
pretend for Simplicity everything's
uniform
so I'll write these just notationally
Uki will be this composition that lifts
functions from Level I to level K so
this is
composition of UK minus 1 through UI and
similarly
DKI is going to be the function that the
operator that takes a function up here
and lowers it all the way down to I by
repeatedly lowering
and this is
uh
the opposite this will be
DK
now to di plus one
okay so these are the composed operators
maybe I'll move
back paper to this board and now I re
discussed how we can compose these
operators to get a series of random
walks on the complex which I think
typically people call higher order
random walks I don't quite remember what
a re called them but the basic version
of this
and the one that will mostly focus on
analyzing is the lower walk which is
UK minus one DK which starts at a
function
or you know you think about it as a
random walk it starts at some case at up
in XK it moves down by removing a
uniformly random element in Sigma and
then it moves back up to level K by
adding in another vertex which completes
to a case set in the complex so this is
what's called the down up block I think
we'll probably hear a lot more about
this related things in Qui quiz talks
but it'll also be very important for us
so I'll note again we can use these
compositions to make longer and
different walks in the complex right so
I could also I could also look at Uki
DKI and this would be a similar process
where I walk down to level I and back up
and if I wanted to do something like
generalize the noise operator I guess
either I could do this person process
which I hadn't thought of
um or you can take a convex combination
of these longer walks and you know maybe
State as an exercise that you can
generalize T row is something like k2's
I rho to the eye you know whatever some
binomial distribution to the set size of
the set that I'm resampling
uh times this
longer walk
Uki
don't worry too much about about this if
you don't follow largely we'll just
focus on this walk which is simpler so
then the last thing that I want to do
here
um I actually want to look at this walk
on a particular complex uh to show you
that it's something that we're very
familiar with that we've seen before I'm
going to show you what this looks like
on the hyperkey
which uh hopefully people in the last
few days have have seen so I can think
about the
the hypercube
I can think about this as a k
dimensional part-time simplicial complex
if I want to be formal about this then
what's X1 this is the set of vertices
for each coordinate I'm going to have
sort of an appended thing that stands
for the color so it's going to be like
one
and then this will be cross uh
zero one so these vertices will be
basically these these pairs where here
is a coordinate one through K and here
is a bit zero or one and then what I get
is actually you know when I look at XK
is actually a complex that a re
mentioned which is the complete
multi-partite complex what I do is I
take all possible combinations of K
vertices that have one of each Index
right and this this really does just
give
the the hyperkey
um and what happens if I apply
this down up walk the hypercube well
this is exactly the process you know I
have
I'll cheat a little bit
you know say I'm at some some K length
string again really what is this this is
actually like one comma one this is
actually two comma zero in my simplicial
complex land but I can sort of just
phrase it like like this what does the
down up walk do it picks a uniformly
random one of these elements so a
uniformly random bit in my string and
then it removes it
and moves sort of down one level and
then it resamples a possible vertex that
completes to Something in the complex
well I only have two options I have to
replace this coordinate so I replace it
with zero with 50 probability and one
with 50 probability
and this is exactly this lazy hyper
Creek graph
so these sort of theory of higher order
random walks you know and if we went
through this very explicitly we would
indeed see that the noise operator on
the on the cube gives you the noise
operator back so there's a there's a
true generalization in terms of these
sort of Kaylee type noise operators on
the cube into General operators on
simplicial complexes or even as it
mentioned two more General types of
Post-its like the gross button and
objects like this so we'll basically
focus on this in partial case for this
talk okay I think the last thing
that I'm supposed to do here is I
haven't reminded you what high
dimensional expander is so let me do
that and then and then we'll finally get
to building a function basis how am I
doing on time okay I think we're fine
um
okay uh I'll
I'll erase that yeah what is the s i how
does that relate to sorry s is supposed
to be the index
so this is like the coordinate one
through one through K and this is the
bit value for the coordinate so you need
to have one of each index and then
anything of zero or
x one is K times
uh X1 uh yes sorry sorry I what I meant
to write was the Union
over sorry I equals one to K
of I across thank you yeah
right so so each of each of these should
have uh an index one for month okay
thank you good catch
um okay let me remind people what uh how
you mentioned launch Banner is I'll
erase this because we're going to
rewrite a theorem that says basically
this in a couple of minutes
um
but
okay so we had two definitions of high
dimensional expanders that are we
mentioned and this talk we'll actually
only need the random mock definition but
in the next talk we will need the local
spectral definition so I'm going to give
both here and then next stock I'm not
going to repeat the local spectral
definition so I lied slightly about the
talk speed completely independent
um
the definition
X
is a Formula you'd call this a gamma
local spectral expander I'm just going
to call it a gamma HDX all right
one-sided
DX
I'm now realizing I needed to Define
links which I didn't do so let me let me
hear where we had a simplicial complex
Define define links for people
so this was one of the main definitions
that are went through so I'll go through
it a little bit more quickly
so given a subset s
uh
in the complex it can come from any of
these levels the link
X of s
you can again sort of view it over in
this diagram like say I have something
in some s in level I and I want to take
the link
one way to think about this is I look I
look up in this diagram at everything
that contains s and then I remove s that
will give me a lower dimensional
simplicial complex that's called the
link so slightly more formally we can
write this as all T and X
such that t Union
s
is also in an X so you can also write
this as like T UNS without s which is
what I said over over here so these are
the links and if you're in a
distribution world there's some induced
Distribution on here again we'll just
assume it's it's uniform
um so uh X is a one-sided gamma HDX if
for all
subsets in X of size at most uh
Dimension minus two
uh then the graph
the underlying
graph
XS one
excess two is a
one-sided
uh yeah my spectral expander
okay so this was the original definition
that Eric gave a local spectral
expansion that's probably currently the
most common definition of of spectral
High dimensional expansion that's used
and then a re introduce the second
definition
that used the random walks maybe let me
say briefly uh a Reit also looked so we
looked here at the at the down up walk
you can also of course look at the up
down walk uh
maybe I shouldn't be at the top of the
complex
um
so we can we can compose U and D so we
could do u k minus
UK minus one
DK this would be the operator that
starts here walks up and walks down and
then a redefined uh sort of the non-lazy
version
of this let's let's pretend there's some
x k plus one up here so I can keep using
uh okay sorry about that
um
I redefined the non-lazy version of this
operator as MK plus so as she noted when
you when you add one thing there's a
chance there's a one over K chance that
you remove it when you come back down so
this just removes that uh that chance
and she defined this notion of random
walk High dimensional expanders
she said X is a
uh
am a random walk
HDX
basically for all levels of the of the
complex
we have that uh the
non-lazy up down walk at level I uh
minus is similar spectrally to the to
the down off walk it's similar to UI
minus one
yeah I particularly the the operator
Norm of this is at most yeah
okay and I reprove this theorem we're
only going to use One Direction of it
that uh any
gamma I guess two-sided
yeah my HDX
is a gamma random walk
okay and
we will actually just use this
definition in in building the basis okay
I think we we now have all the tools
that we need to actually build uh build
the foia basis
what is the Mi plus Mi plus is the
non-lazy up down walk so it's the yeah I
just remove the one over I chance of
removing of uh coming to the same thing
sorry
UD is
UD is down okay this is very annoying UD
is down up yes the operators are
fighting this direction but when you
think about it as a random Walk This is
actually the down step of the random
walk and this is actually the upset with
the random walk so if you're looking
like the sampling literature you'll see
this definition flipped uh so this is
like the function operator version of
the definition versus the random block
version of the definition
um sorry there was another question
the question was uh the other one is
also negative but it's only a Time ah
yes so on it the other walk is also lazy
and if you wanted to do this in terms of
like uh what's called a sequentially
differential post set or like you're
willing to be really careful you would
also remove the laziness of this but you
can show that in a gamma High
dimensional expander
uh in a two-sided expander you cannot
have much laziness because it you could
prove that it would force the Spectrum
to have a large eigenvalue so the the
eigenvalue here will always be like at
most or the laziness will always be the
most gamma so we don't have to worry
about it it's a good question and just
just for my like the the uh down up walk
that's that's representing the part of
the spectrum you don't care about
uh you're getting rid of I mean yeah
this is I mean this is like generalized
if you have this on the first level this
would be like the stationary
distribution yes I'm addressing I would
get rid of like the constant functions
for the laplacian that's what I would
subtract yeah that's what the I'm just
distinguishing the two operators that's
the up down is the
part of the spectrum yeah I mean in a
sense when you're at higher levels like
this is it's not a trivial part of the
spectrum anymore because there's like
structures on but you're sort of
subtracting out the lower levels uh of
the object
um
yeah okay and as you say like this is
anything for the camera so you can't
think about it yes a subtracting output
the constant part okay
um so let's actually move to this
function to composition
um
I think maybe erase this
okay so the averaging operators I think
you know we we said or I said sort of
the beginning that morally we want to
think about the compositions by level we
want to think about fi as being
functions that come from Level y of a
complex and now we really have a way to
talk about this right we have ways to
lift and lower functions throughout the
complex these are also used to define
higher order random walks and so we'll
also sort of want to build this basis
that acts nicely with respect to these
operators
so let me make sort of like a first
attempt of defining uh what it means to
come from up y as a function
so it's sort of our goal here will be to
Define
what it means to be like a level I
function then we'll use this to build a
basis so one very natural definition is
I would you know if I'm trying to build
a basis I'll say for CK for this top
level up here and I'll say something is
level I if it's literally a function on
level I that's then
lifted up to level K right so one
natural the first thing that I think you
would consider is you know functions F
that are equal to Uki GI in other words
things that are in the image
of this living your operator Uki
so this is this is almost what we want
but like standard techniques in building
a basis we need to subtract out the
parts that are coming from below right
this isn't really just level I you know
GI could have been a function that was a
function that was lifted you know GI
could have actually come from I minus
one we want to rule out the case we want
to you know subtract out everything
that's coming from below we want to rule
out this case that GI is actually a
lower level function on the complex
and so to do this we'll look at this
space
where we only lift functions GI and we
want to ensure that GI is uh in the
orthogonal complement
of things that come
from one level below so we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna Force
lifting functions at level I that are
orthogonal to everything that are coming
from below and this has a very nice
representation
because the
so maybe I should uh
of course write this over here so the
image of UI minus one this is something
that lives on level I here it's things
that are being mapped up because the
operators U and B are adjoint
the curb space of this image is just
equal to the kernel
of it's Android the kernel of the down
operation so this suggests the following
definition of level I functions
the inner product
uh it's just the expectation over
assets so if this is if this is at level
I this is the expectation over ice
that's drawn from our complex of f of
Tau
um and like we mentioned before in
reality this has some induced
distribution to make sure everything's
adjoint but we'll assume everything's uh
uniform
okay so this suggests the following
definition of level I functions or the
is that not going to cause a problem at
any point no it never causes it because
you actually Define like you don't
actually Define this to be uniform at
level I right it's actually defined to
be the distribution over level I because
I draw something from the top level and
then I take a random subset and I Define
everything with respect to this induced
distribution so you can think of it as
every time I'm actually drawing a joint
distribution from every level of the
complex then when I talk about
individual things I marginalizing over
this distribution this will this will
enforce that there's never a problem
with this sort of thing
I'm confused because you said I mean so
so when it's not uniform there's like no
if if your complex is not it's only
uniform if your complex were completely
up regular then if you did this induced
distribution if every if every iset is
in the same number of K sets then it
would truly be uniform and everything
would work this is not generically true
and when it's not true it's the
distribution is not uniform so I'm I'm
making the implicit assumption here that
the complex has regular up degree as
well which is totally unnecessary and
you don't need it but it simplifies
things because that everything is
so yeah you cannot think of it as
uniform in general in the general case
you need to be a design if you know
usually a design it needs to be a design
yeah
so at some point as computer scientists
maybe we can stop treating the uniform
distribution as if it's the you know the
only thing in the world
the weighted things and I was advised to
throw out the weighted architects
um
yeah I agree
uh but I will say you can also for an
HDX as a way to normal regularize them
so that this is actually true well it's
not necessary okay what was I doing
so I wanted to find the space of level I
functions
so
we'll denote this as uh DKI so this is
the the space of functions on CK that
comes from Level I and this is just
going to be
the up operator applied to the kernel
the eye and then I'll Define
because there's no down operator at the
bottom level
the zero with space here is just going
to be constants
or equivalently this is the image of
things the lift of things at level zero
the only possible lift of the empty set
is constant functions so I can also just
think of this as the image of uk0
okay and finally we can State uh
we can State this theorem which we'll
replace here
[Music]
yeah so this is we're trying to
decompose functions
on the case level and we're saying that
we're okay being like an arbitrary level
or like just think of it as the top
level
um really you can do I mean I can always
cut the complex off at some Dimension so
I can always do this at any level of the
complex but for Simplicity uh think of
it as the top Dimension I think you
don't actually need this K plus one
just think of it as the top level and
we're saying the top level can always be
decomposed into uh the part that comes
from hey sex the part that comes from K
minus one sets all the way down the
complex and this is the theorem that I'm
about to write
um so this is a result
due to addiction
in our
illness
and Harsha which raises the question of
why I'm talking about it
um
which is essentially answers the
question that we had at the beginning of
the talk that indeed this sort of
decomposition exists so they say on a
gamma random walk
HDX where I think we'll Force gamma to
be less than
1 over K minus one we'll see why that's
the case
um
we have
one
that this uh
this set of spaces is indeed a
decomposition of CK so we have that CK
is equal to
uh
bk0 Plus
V K so in other words I can always
decompose you know equivalently I can I
can say I can always write f
as the sum of of f i uniquely
where
f i is equal to Uki GI
and GI is in the kernel of the down
operator
this is an equivalent way to phrase
things and I'll just mention that I made
a little bit or
if you're familiar with sort of building
the site before you get a composition I
made a little bit of an odd Choice here
when I just looked at sort of the kernel
at level I
if I wanted to build a truly orthogonal
basis I would have made sure that I was
orthogonal to sort of being lifted all
the way up the complex and you can do
this this is studied in work of Kaufman
and oppenheim and it gets you an
orthogonal decomposition but what it
what it doesn't get you is this sort of
really elegant uh formalization for how
f is written in terms of the averaging
operators and we'll see that actually
having G have this very simple
explanation of being in the kernel of
the down operator will be extremely
useful
um we'll see this explicitly so uh
just to say you could Define uh we'll
see maybe I'll say first step two to
explain this this is not actually an
orthogonal basis it's an approximately
orthogonal basis so we'll have that
fi of
FJ is less than or equal to
some term in gamma times the norm of fi
times the norm of FJ
there's a lot of lines but
um so it won't be truly orthogonal but
typically this is sort of at least in
this context of analysis this is good
enough we can take gamma to be as small
as we want and so this can be as close
to zero as as you want
um and the third
is that it will be approximately so I
should write here sort of
orthogonality
here approximate
so it will satisfy this approximate uh
approximate will be eigenvectors both of
the noise operator the down up block
um but we'll focus just on the down off
block for for Simplicity
so we'll have that
uh
UD
f i
minus K minus I over K so the same
eigenvalues that you saw when we applied
it on the hypercube
again these won't be exactly equal but
they will be close in two more right so
this will be again less than or equal to
some error term in k
times the norm
that fi okay 20 I have 20 minutes
approximately 15. okay so this is the
the statement of the theorem
um which I mean I haven't shown you how
to prove this at all yet but uh it gives
a resolution to this question we had at
the beginning of the talk so are there
any questions about the theorem
statement itself before I go to trying
to prove it luckily the proof is is once
you have all this Machinery set up it's
not so hard
okay with respect to gamma
uh no there's some recent work on this
that isn't on archive yet that improves
so here it's going to be horrible it's
going to be like exponent it'll be like
K choose I or something like that this
shouldn't be necessary and I know
there's some ongoing work about this
that isn't posted yet but I don't think
we know uh maybe with respect to exactly
this decomposition or exactly right what
the right value should be
so so this theorem will only apply to
very strong High dimensional offenders
and this is something that I've uh been
annoyed about for a while when you look
at something like the symmetric group
you can actually express it as a high
dimensional expander but at codimension
J its expansion is like 1 over J squared
whereas I need like you know if you're
over SN you need like one over two to
the N or something so there's a huge gap
in sort of weak and strong High
dimensional expenders and this really
only applies currently uh to Strong high
dimensional offenders it's not clear if
that's necessary or not yeah
exactly
no they are sorry no no there's uh oh
sorry you mean um like to build a truly
orthogonal account so you can make you
can make this truly zero you can't make
this truly zero yeah
um I mean you could you could just look
at the I get There's an actual eigen
basis that would be that would be truly
zero but uh I don't think the eigen
basis will actually truly correspond to
these uh like have these nice forums in
terms of the random it's impossible
because
the cluster but they're not the same so
yeah yeah
yeah so this this we can make zero at
the cost of being very complicated this
there's sort of no hope if you want to
Define it like this
yeah
right yeah the eigenvalues aren't just
this anyway is there a way to write down
the GI
like as a projection onto something or
um I don't know how to explicitly write
GI yeah some expression in the UND yeah
I mean you right you can't I I think
there is some
you know some are actually to answer
this question I did go through and write
explicitly things out to make sure that
the basis wasn't orthogonal yeah you can
express it as some linear equations in
terms of this but I I don't know like a
nice like it's the projection onto this
space or I I yeah I don't I don't know
um and actually the fact that this does
this is like the to me this is like the
main negative of this basis the fact
that it doesn't have a nice explicit way
of talking about it and I won't get to
it unfortunately but there are other
bases based on like Efron Stein that
have a very explicit form that you can
use and those don't work as well with
the random box but they work well with
other things because they have some sort
of explicit representation okay but let
me move to the proof that we can
actually see some things
I'm a little bits
um
okay so let's first prove that we
actually get a decomposition
will approve uh this guy first
foreign
so this is this is a fairly easy
induction that will run into an issue at
at one step
um okay so in particular the the
base case of this
uh is actually trivial the base case has
like a Zero Dimensional complex where
all I have is the empty set and then
that space of functions is the constant
base of functions so for k equals zero
the space c0 is indeed V 0 0 which is
just the constant functions this is a
sort of a trivial base case
um
in the general setting
if I take c k I mean the idea is
to just take I mean it shouldn't be that
surprising from what we've done here I
can split d k c k into the
because DK is a linear operator I can
flip this into the kernel of DK
correct sum with its uh
orthogonal complements and we talked
about earlier that due to a jointness
this is just the image of UK minus one
right so again
kernel of DK lives here at level K its
complement is functions that are being
raised from one level below
so this is equal to
kernel of DK or maybe I'll write so
kernel of DK is vkk right this is from
definition
we've got the first part of our basis
so now this is just the image
of UK minus 1 and I actually want to
think about this
as
UK minus 1 applied
to CK minus one right applied to the
space of functions what level below and
then now I'm going to attempt
to induct to say I have the
decomposition on CK minus one and I'll
try to lift it uh to this two
composition here so this is vkk Plus
UK minus one
times this decomposition I'm cheating a
little bit of the notation but
bear with me
so by induction this can be decomposed
into uh
these level functions
and notice that by definition hopefully
I kept it here right so vki is is just
lifting the kernel at level d i all the
way up so in particular
if I or maybe I'll write here
by definition we have that
UK minus one
a v k minus one I this is exactly uh
sorry this is exactly
vki right I'm just adding an extra U
here so if
if I consider get this to be associative
and pass this through uh this this
composition then I would be done I'm
writing a star here because I'm cheating
you can't actually do this
um but if if I could pass you through
these parentheses then
you know I would get something that
looks like
what's this
or I maybe should have flipped the order
of these but this this would come if
this step magical step worked this would
complete the theorem right this would
now be
BKK and then
I shouldn't have flipped the orders but
you know BK
okay minus one
down to VK zero okay and indeed just to
get a decomposition that's not
necessarily a unique decomposition you
could do this right there's there's
nothing wrong with with doing that if I
don't want to maintain uniqueness but in
order to maintain a unique
representation I actually need this
operator to be injected I need it to be
injective at every level because I'm
using an inductive assumption here so
really the the true version of this
theorem says that on any complex where
this op operator is injective throughout
every level then I get this
decomposition so what we have to prove
is that on again a random walk HDX it
turns out
if as long as you select you I'm going
to be less than one over K minus one
that these operators are indeed
injective
so I'll write sort of this claim which
completes the theorem
that on a uh gamma random walk
HDX
UI is
injective
at all
levels uh
I'm going to sketch the proof of it I
want to get to the other thing so I'm
not going to be super formal but the
idea of this is to say
how do I prove this is in uh this is
injective I want to show it has no
kernel so I want to show that for any
non-zero function that uif
uif is
greater than zero right if I can show
that this or equivalently remember that
U and U and D are adjoints so this is
the same as asking that if f d u f is a
positive definite operator
and the idea roughly is to say that I
can switch between d u
H great I still have it up I can switch
between d u and UD I've written it
slightly differently here because this
is the the plus version of the operator
but an equivalent way to write this
just expanding out what this is is the
lazy versus non-lazy version of the
operator I can write this as D I uh UI
minus 1 so this is the up down walk that
has the laziness portion
um
minus
the laziness
for the correctly normalized uh down up
walk
all right it's a little small
but this uh in two Norm
is it most I minus 1 over I times gamma
I haven't actually done anything I just
unfolded like the lazy versus non-lazy
versions so that I can look at directly
flipping down up and up down at the cost
of this factor of one over I and in
laziness and now I'm basically just
going to do exactly this right I'm going
to take uh I'm going to take f
I'm going to say that up to some
error factor in like I minus 1 over I
gamma
that's F that this is the same
as 1 over I
f f plus uh
f
UDF so there's some error term in here
that scales with gamma but otherwise I
get this laziness portion one over I and
I get fudf again F UDF can be written as
DF DF so this is a positive
semi-definite part so this is always
greater than zero so what I'm left with
is that uh this guy
is greater than or equal to 1 over I
f f minus I minus 1 over I gamma
FF and so as long as gamma is always
better than one over I minus 1 which
we've assumed by uh in in the theorem
statement then this is indeed
truly greater than zero in the
operator's injected so on on a high
dimensional expander uh you always get
this type of true unique decomposition
I
so d u and u d are both
positive semi-definite because if I'm
just looking at the inner product
I can trade the U to a d over here by a
jointness
this is this is a norm so it's it's all
this is like a square sum of squares so
this is always greater than or equal to
zero so I'm just I'm using a jointness
if you indeed to prove that they're all
PSD
the trick is to show that it's actually
strictly definiteness positive definite
in this case
okay
okay uh I think I have enough time to
show the basic proof for so I'm going to
prove three next two is actually an
immediate consequence of three it's
right you could prove it directly but uh
you can you can prove approximate
orthogonality sort of instantly from
this so I'll mention it at the
at the end
okay I think I'm finally gonna erase
this post set diagram
hopefully we've got our uh our use out
of that
okay so we want to prove this uh the
fact that the spaces isn't approximate
eigen basis
um let's look first at a very easy case
let's look at vkk which is just the
kernel
of DK so if I have a function in here
hopefully it's obvious that this is an
eigenfunction
of the lower walk right in particular
this is zero
so this is zero times F of K
and we have at least at the top level is
a true eigenvector okay this was sort of
a trivial case but it's not far from
what we're actually going to do to prove
the the general case and in fact I'm
just going to do V K minus one and the
other the rest of the cases will follow
basically exactly the same argument
so now let's say I have F in uh V K
minus 1. so in other words
F K minus 1 is equal to UK minus one
g k minus one where
d k minus 1 is in the kernel
of the down operator
right this was the definition of our of
our space
now I want to look at
I'm going to look at UD uh
K minus 1 of f k minus one okay this is
equal to I'm going to maybe drop the
indices
uh
UD U
of g k minus one so g k minus 1 is in
the kernel of d right the natural thing
to do is now to apply
the random walk theorem and flip D and u
right so I can replace
d u up to some term in gamma so maybe
let's let's write gamma is equal to uh
this this difference
d u minus one over I I minus I minus one
over I uh
UD so I can replace this with u
1 over I I plus I minus 1 over I sorry k
a minus 1 over K times u d
K minus 1 plus gamma formerly you gamma
apply to g k minus one right I've done
I've done nothing in this step I've just
added and subtracted something but now
remember that
gamma this is a matrix that has operator
Norm
at most of gamma and what happens here
well this
this down operator now hits GK minus one
and this term dies right so this is this
becomes zero because this is in the
kernel of the down operator and so what
I'm left with is one over K times uh
just times U of g k minus 1 which is
what
by definition this was whatever K times
F K minus one so when I go through this
process of flipping one part of D and U
I pick up a factor of 1 over K and
indeed if I were to do this generally
but if I were to look at like high
levels down then I would flip I times
and I would get a factor of I over K and
I would continue doing this flipping
process and you you gain these error
terms that look like this form but so at
the end of the day what do I have
let's just do the K minus one case
so I have something that looks like this
and I wanted to say that in two Norm
that this and this were close right what
I was trying to prove
was that uh UDF K minus 1 minus one over
k
F K minus one
was small so now I can shift this over
to the left side and I can say that this
so far what I've managed to prove is
that this is indeed less than or equal
to
U gamma of g k minus one
and because the operator Norm of this is
bounded and U is an averaging operator
so it's a contraction this is at most o
of gamma times
the norm of g k minus one
so we're almost done except I have a
problem which is that I wanted to get
error in terms of f k minus one and I
have yeah oh two minutes got it I I
think I just have time to finish this I
have error in terms of g k minus one
but we can just again apply the same
trick to fix this I want to relate
GK minus one GK minus 1 to what I wanted
right which was half K minus one
F K minus one uh I guess people can't
see here
move over here
so F K minus one
F K minus one is uh
is u g u g
is again I'm just going to do the same
trick is G
dug now I flip the operators
so this uh
this will get like a one over K factor
from the identity
of GG plus something that's like DG
DG plus some o of gamma error term from
flipping this is zero because again
these are in the kernel of the down
operator so I get up to some error term
a relation between the two Norm of G
squared two Norm of G and the square two
or of f
and so finally I can go back
to this step here and up to including
some extra air Factor here I can get
that this is less than or equal to K
times gamma times the norm of uh F K
minus one
which is what we actually wanted to
prove and if you want to do this for
General I it's really the same the only
difference is that there will be a few
more use here and I just have to do this
as many times as there are used it's the
exact same proof okay I don't have time
to show approximal orthogonality but it
turns out if you have this type of
behavior and you have a self-adjoint
operator I can always look at like the
operator applied
I can look at the difference of UD f i
FJ which is equal to f i u d f j because
itself a joint but these will have
correspond to different approximate
eigenvalues so this can only happen when
fifj is very small so you can use this
to immediately get approximate
orthogonality parts of all and all the
things that come from it okay I'm out of
time so I'll stop here
[Applause]
yeah
any questions
I have a comment so I think I've seen
here is really work with Stanley
so the only thing we did is
any more comments over
questions
it seems like we're developing this
theory of bully analysis on on the
spectral or random walk hdx's you know a
Reit also talked about
um
co-boundary expansion and stuff like
this is there an analogous Theory or
to be seen I don't know and I I guess
I don't even really know what it would
mean to do this over F2 versus
yeah I I really don't know
um I mean I know that there doesn't
exist an analogous Theory here at least
maybe there should be one
you just have spaces
but that's that's it you can do it over
General Post-its but everything's still
real valued like these averaging offers
so one thing that is really nice is that
this whole process I just use this
random walk that you're gonna post that
I didn't use simplicial structure at all
so unlike things that I'll talk about in
the next talk this all generalizes to
Grossman and things like this but it's
still all real valued all the averaging
operators are real value averages and in
co-boundary they're have two sons
so
so what happens for General process like
your bounds are much worse because there
is no drama like what is Stanley Oh Oh
you mean so sequentially differential
Pro sets are basically when you uh you
have this
equivalence for some RI and Qi and this
is exactly equal to zero and then you
can you can run through all this Theory
and Gamma is equal to zero if you want
to do this on a general post set
I mean the only thing that changes if
you have an approximate version is that
this one over I what was this coming
from this was coming from the regularity
of a simplicial complex so this comes
from the fact that when I move up and
then down I have a one over I my
regularity is one over I really the only
thing that changes is that this becomes
the downward regularity of the post set
that you're looking at and then the
corresponding eigenvalues like in the
gross menu you'll get like 1 over Q to
the I which happens to do with if you're
over like uh fq
um the error terms I mean they also blow
up with this regularity like when I
relate two things across different
levels there's a blow up by the
regularity parameter so if the
regularity is huge you get a huge blow
up in the thinner parameters
okay so let's take any more questions
offline so let's thank Max again
[Applause]
so we meet again in epoxy